hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear show this is where i review
various movies now i know that i said
that i was going back to the winter
movies in january but again
i feel like i did it the last couple
times and then i was just like [ __ ] it i
can't i can't do it and there's too many
there's too many like movies that i want
to do that i really need to get to and
not all of them are winter themed i did
kind of want to do that but it's very
sporadic so you know sorry about that so
this movie actually
this was one that really flew under my
radar actually i think it flew under a
lot of people's radar because i really
don't see that much
i mean there's some reviews of it but i
don't think it really got anything
approximating a wide release or anything
and uh that's kind of a shame because
this is actually not a bad little uh
little movie
now i heard about it
because a few weeks back or later right
around christmas when i reviewed the
2003 movie dead end um that movie has
linshay in it like playing the mom
and somebody on the comments of that
video said oh you should watch this
movie from 2019 called room for rent
because linshay is kind of like you know
the main character and not a lot of
people have seen it so i was like well
that actually sounds pretty good so i
went ahead and watched it because it was
on uh 2b for free
and as i said this not a bad little
movie at all i don't know
i guess it's kind of like horror
adjacent i would call it more like a
psychological thriller sort of like
maybe along the lines of like single
white female or
you know something or pacific heights or
something like that like about
like a creepy
landlord type situation but not really
any horror elements maybe until the end
but
honestly i think this is a really really
good character study and lynn shay is
great in it i mean she just pretty much
carries the whole movie now the movie is
quite short it's only about an hour and
20 minutes long but honestly so it does
kind of feel like it moves along like at
a really good kind of you know pace or a
really quick pace and maybe it could
have been a little bit longer like 10 or
20 minutes longer just to like flesh out
some of the other characters a little
bit more but honestly that didn't really
bother me all that much um i mean this
is linshay's show pretty much there are
a few other characters but not all that
many
so i think pretty much the only place
that this sort of got a wide or you know
got a lot of people to see it was at uh
the sedona international film festival
like in early 2019 and i believe this
movie was shot in sedona arizona as well
it like it looks like arizona but please
correct me if i'm wrong about that so
what this movie is about it was actually
it was directed by tommy stovall i'm not
really sure i think he's done a couple
of other kind of indie films but i
haven't seen them so what this movie is
about lynn shay uh plays this woman
named joyce
and at the very beginning of the movie
um her husband dies
in what is ostensibly an accident and uh
it looks like he was up there like on
the roof trying to fix something or do
something on the roof and he slipped and
fell off and he died so that happens
like pretty much in the very first scene
so after that uh she discovers she seems
like she's kind of uh you know shell
shocked as you would be
and uh as it turns out
she kind of has
this is an interest and it's again this
is another one and i don't really want
to spoil a lot about it because it's not
really that old um you know it only came
out in 2019 and i feel like maybe a lot
of people haven't seen it and i and
honestly i don't know why because
linshay is like particularly in the
horror community is so well known
because of her you know uh you know with
being in big franchises and stuff but
this was is another one that just kind
of like went under the radar so i don't
really want to spoil the twists and
turns but again if i'm gonna talk about
it
you know i'm gonna have to inevitably
like spoil a few plot points otherwise i
won't be able to talk about it at all
but uh yeah so she seems like
kind of you're not really sure
[Music]
let's put it this way you're not really
sure how much of what she says or how is
uh accurate let's put it that way she's
kind of like i don't say unreliable
narrator just not narrating it
necessarily but
she's maybe not
mentally stable so you're not entirely
sure if some of the stuff she says is
true or not
so let's just put it that way
so after her husband dies um you can
tell she has some ambivalent feelings
about it because as i said she seemed
like she's sort of like shocked because
it was sudden
but she also seems like she is kind of
like maybe glad he's dead a little bit
in the sense that well there's one scene
where she's at the funeral and i think
the only person at the funeral is like
the nurse of like her neighbor
who's like a friend of hers i guess
and so there's no one else at the
funeral so that kind of suggests some
things too you know whether this was a
likable dude or not
i think his name was fred like the
husband
now she finds out that
fred
didn't le he only had one account left
and it only had two hundred dollars in
it but he had also taken out loans and
he still owed six thousand dollars on
the loans so she's pretty much left with
nothing like with no money and she still
has to pay for the house and all this
other stuff now you see her kind of
early on
doing some [ __ ] like she goes in his
study
and she's like
putting like she has the big urn like
with his ashes and she's just kind of
like she doesn't seem to know where to
put it like she just kind of chucks it
in a bottom drawer and like she opens up
this other drawer and there's like kind
of all these porn magazines and stuff
and she just like disgustedly like
throws him in this other drawer so you
can tell she's got some real ambivalent
uh feelings about this and honestly and
this is i don't know i don't know if i
want to say this or not because maybe
it's a spoiler but all right so i'm
gonna say i'm not entirely sure and the
movie never tells you whether the
husband's death was actually an accident
or not that's all i'm gonna say all
right so
so she's been uh left by this dude with
no money
and needs to find a way to make some so
she's in the library one day checking
out uh her very favorite romance novel
that's kind of another thing that uh is
sort of a through line throughout the
movie is that she's really into
this whole fantasy based all you know
all these kind of like smutty
romance novels and she's like at the
library and the librarian's like oh
you've checked this one out before and
i'm like damn nosey [ __ ] she's like
yeah i really like this one it has a
happy ending so she's read that one like
three or four times now while she's in
the library she sees something that's
like an ad for it's essentially airbnb
but they can't call it that so i guess
it's share b b or something like that
now uh because she is
she's an old person she doesn't know
what that is so it's like kind of funny
like
the thing about her character in this is
that it's funny because she's clueless
like she doesn't really know how
anything works uh she doesn't know what
airbnb is she doesn't know how to use
apps on a phone or anything like that
she doesn't know what i don't think she
even knows what app means
um so it's kind of like you know an okay
boomer kind of thing where you're just
kind of like okay again with the program
grandma but you also like feel a lot of
sympathy for her
because as the movie goes on you figure
out that maybe her husband wasn't the
nicest dude and she does seem like a
nice lady who means well she's just kind
of out of her she's very sheltered and
so you kind of feel bad and she like she
has some shitty things happen to her
later on it's just like bullying and
stuff like that which i'll get into but
so you actually do kind of feel sorry
for her i will say that
um i'm not sure like what your
your capacity for this is but because
she's so
likable but also because she's kind of
like pitiful it's almost like it's
really like kind of cringe inducing like
to watch her character for the first
probably half of the movie just because
you feel
kind of terrible
that
she's kind of having to go through all
this stuff and she's not real
savvy about things um you know which
i'll get into in a little bit too so
i was kind of like watching it and i was
kind of like looking at it like that
because i was like oh man i was like so
i know it's a movie but i was like so
kind of embarrassed for her like
embarrassed for her character because
i'm like holy crap oh my god that's like
so sad so
it's really it's a really good
performance because she has this like
real psychological complexity to her
where as it goes on and you're kind of
determining that
maybe she's not as truthful as she might
have been or maybe she's not as mentally
stable as as you thought she was maybe
she's not as well-meaning as you thought
she was it kind of gives you like these
conflicted feelings about her because
she does seem like a nice lady that
can't really
help being like that so it's just kind
of like it's like i said it's a really
good um psychological like a character
study of her
so she decides well to uh she figures
out i think she calls it what's a she
says what's a banib because it's like
bnb she doesn't know what that is
so um she's like oh i get it so she
looks it up on her computer and she's
like oh that's a good idea because now
she has all these spare rooms so she
decides she's going to open up her house
as an airbnb
or a share bb whatever same thing
and so it immediately jumps to her doing
exactly that now there are a couple of
scenes in here too where they show her
kind of like walking to the store i mean
she's kind of like she has one cat whose
name is boodle who's a black cat who's
adorable by the way and
thankfully nothing bad happens to the
cat and honestly the cat's kind of like
cool because the cat's real chill and
this little black cat is like laying on
the bed and the thing just being like
yeah i'm a cat and i'm just kind of like
look at that adorable cat i guess see i
get like [ __ ] distracted by cats and
movies all the time but i'm just glad
i'm just very happy to report that
nothing bad happened to boodle so don't
worry about it when you because as soon
as i saw boodle i was like oh no i was
like something bad's gonna happen to
that kitty but nothing does so you know
so don't worry about that
so she kind of like has to walk back and
forth like to get cat food and whatnot
and there's these scenes in there where
you know her card's not working and like
she has to pay with change and i was
like oh no and it's like and you can see
like the girl behind the counter going
oh [ __ ] me you know what i mean because
look i've been behind those people too
that had coupons for 40 bajillion things
and had to pay with rolls of pennies or
[ __ ] change they got out of their
couch or something and it's just you
know uh so yeah so i kind of felt bad
because i was like yeah i'd hate to be
that person that was like checking her
out or that was behind her but then
again you feel kind of bad for her too
because her husband essentially like
took all her body and then croaked so
there was that whole issue
so one day when she's coming back from
the store
there's kind of these uh teenagers that
hang out at this sort of like skate park
that's like right in her neighborhood
and i guess they kind of know
who she is because she's lived there a
long time and so every time she walks by
they start like harassing her and
honestly at one point it gets like
really bad like one of the kids
essentially like just grabs her and is
like trying to you know pull up her
skirt and all this other kind of stuff
and this is like a 70 75 year old woman
and so these kids are just like the
[ __ ] worst so
so you feel bad for her then too because
she's getting like you know bullied and
essentially like sexually assaulted by
these [ __ ] teenage boys at this park
so that's like another shitty thing
so she opens up her airbnb and her first
customers
are this couple whose names are sarah
and edward and sarah has come there
they're on vacation in arizona and she's
been thinking about writing a book and
since it's set in arizona she's like oh
i wanted to stay here for a couple weeks
and get a feel for the place so you know
so i could take notes or whatever her
boyfriend edward is a gigantic like
douche canoe and uh is real hostile like
right from the beginning he's like you
know i don't want to stay here why are
we even doing this let's go to a hotel
blah blah blah and he's just really
cranky now
you can understand because as i said
lynn shay's character joyce
she doesn't know like what the
parameters of running an airbnb are
so she essentially treats these people
like they're her kids or like guests in
her house rather than like paying
you know what i mean so she'll like she
puts them in a room and then she comes
up and just like opens the door hey i
made you some cookies you know what i
mean and he's like
this is our room like why you made it
like she doesn't really understand the
boundaries you know what i mean uh so
obviously the boyfriend is pissed off
about it him and the girlfriend have a
fight but sarah feels bad for her and so
then they sort of like strike up a
little bit of a friendship like once
they kind of start talking because like
i said sarah feels bad and so she she
feels bad that her boyfriend is such a
douche so
she kind of like tries to be nice to the
older lady and they like i said they
sort of strike up a friendship now only
a day or two pass the boyfriend says
okay i got us a better place we're
getting the [ __ ] out of here but sarah
feels bad for kind of leaving uh joyce
in the lurch so as the story goes on
uh sarah actually corresponds with joyce
like she starts like writing her letters
and stuff
now after that joyce decides that she's
this airbnb thing is maybe not working
out but she's gonna start renting out
the rooms like as apartments you know
what i mean so she kind of like um you
know fixes a couple of the rooms the
spare rooms up um and her you know fred
her dead husband like fixes up his study
is a spare room
and so is gonna rent them out like
longer term
now the guy that she gets to do this
she's at the library again getting
another one of her romance novels
and she sees a guy who is obviously
who's this kind of like smoldering foxy
type of dude but you can all you can
tell too that he's kind of like
a bad boy type um which you know is
weird for me to say because he's like
you know probably in his 30s but uh but
he looks like he's been in a fight a
little bit like he's got like a little
bit of a cut on his forehead so he looks
a little bit rough but you know
but uh joyce is just kind of like oh you
know what i mean even though this dude
is like young enough to be her grandson
probably maybe son maybe grandson i'm
not entirely sure what the age
difference is
but uh so she sees him
in the library like looking at the board
like looking for a room and she comes in
and she goes oh i know that place um
they're not running anymore but i have a
room so why don't you come in he's just
like okay i just you know i just got out
of town and i need a place to stay
so his name is bob which is for roberto
and
he's like i said he's kind of like you
know he rides a motorcycle no one's
entirely sure what he does for money
um but he seems like a nice dude now as
this goes on joyce develops a very
strange very inappropriate crush on him
let's put it like that uh like a sexual
interest and so she starts you know kind
of dressing up in sort of like sexier
clothes like tottering around in high
heels in the house and putting like
ribbons in her hair and stuff and you
know she's always making him food and
she pays for this expensive satellite
thing so he can watch football because
she heard that he liked it so she's kind
of like building this like delusional
fantasy much like in her romance novels
where this guy is like this decent man
and he's going to come and save her
and
like i said even though he's way younger
now he is like really nice to her he's
kind of like a little bit you know you
know
because like boundaries and stuff
because she does like kind of go in his
room like oh i'm i'm gonna wash your
sheets and he's like yeah do you need to
do that every day though like like why
are you coming in my room all the time
so but he's trying to be nice to her
because like i said she seems like a
nice lady she seems well-meaning
but she's just real invasive and she
doesn't really seem to understand why
people um are kind of like pushing her
away
but she starts
like i said she was still has a
correspondence with sarah like the girl
that stayed there before
and she has starts like making up this
whole
relationship
between her and bob and she doesn't say
it outright but she kind of like implies
that it's sort of like a romance but she
doesn't say like how old bob is or
anything like that but she just says oh
we spent all this time together and this
that and the other and so she does like
these voice-overs where she's you know
saying the letter
and then like in the movie they're
showing what's actually happening in
that bob just has no [ __ ] idea he's
just like a room he's renting and he's
not really all that worried about it um
so there's that you know she's like oh i
went for a ride on his motorcycle and
stuff even though she never did so later
it happens so this kind of whole
uncomfortable situation is developing
and it is very uncomfortable and it gets
even more uncomfortable like as it goes
on
uh but then it sort of like comes to a
head a little bit so it turned out that
the talks she had with sarah um sarah
had been persuaded to leave her
douchebag boyfriend
and she's like oh um i'm gonna be in
town like in arizona like doing
something else and i was just gonna drop
by like an hour and see you
so she does drop by and uh at that point
she meets bob and sees that bob is not
not exactly what she expected
uh so yeah so from there like i said i
don't want to spoil it anymore from
there
but you know [ __ ] starts to get a little
uh complicated like after that point
so as i said this is a pretty short
movie it's not outright horror like it's
not real gory or anything
you know it's not real scary or anything
because a lot of it's like you know
daylit of arizona sunlight and
everything like that it's kind of more
like a psychological study but man lynne
shay is so good in this
she's so good in this that i was just
like i was watching her the whole time
like i said the whole beginning of the
movie like where she was doing stuff
like you know coming into her airbnb
couple's room like with cookies like
without knocking and stuff um because
she figures oh it's my house and they're
just staying here so she's almost kind
of like treating them like her children
even though they're grown adults and
like her doing stuff like that just the
whole time i was like oh god like it was
just so awkward to watch she was just so
so [ __ ] awkward and it just kind of
gets
more like that but then it starts
getting more disturbing as you realize
as the movie goes on that she's kind of
become untethered from reality a little
bit and then you're kind of thinking and
the movie kind of leaves this ambiguous
how long has she been like that you know
what i mean it's just kind of like
you know was she pushed over the edge by
her husband's death you know or the
bullying like the sexual assault or
whatever that she went through with the
teenagers you know did that just like
push her anything or was she like that
before because we don't know what she
was like before so she might have been
like this the whole time and as i said
there's different characters in there
that she's told various things too about
her husband or about like a kid that she
had or something like that and
you never know like if what she's saying
is true or not because there's some
stuff that happens that other people
like contradict uh that maybe would have
known better so
you're not really sure like what you
know how mired in reality she is or if
she just lives in a complete fantasy
land and if she's always been like that
or if that was like a new development so
yeah this is actually a really good like
i said don't expect like a horror [ __ ]
it's more like a psychological study you
know kind of like your
kind of scary renter type of i don't
know it's kind of reminding me like i
said a single white female or not not as
campy or like over the top is that more
i don't know it kind of reminds me a
little bit of one hour photo or
something like that where it was just
kind of like a character study of
somebody that
sort of becomes inappropriately obsessed
with somebody and it's just like a
really really awkward person who maybe
has an entire fantasy life that they
have going on that nobody else like
knows about so it's that kind of movie
but it's really really decent really
worth watching like i said it's pretty
short it's only about an hour 20 minutes
something like that and you can watch it
for free
on 2b
at least as of this recording so hell if
you're a fan of lynn shay uh then you
probably need to see this because this
is a you know it's kind of her show
she's like the main character she's in
the whole thing and uh it's great she's
great in it and uh she should really do
more of these kind of like big leading
roles i guess but yeah it's it's
interesting how this came out a couple
years back and didn't really get a lot
of traction despite how kind of famous
she is particularly in the horror
community but you know uh that's kind of
a shame but [ __ ] happens so you know how
that is uh but yeah go to 2b and watch
it if you're a lynche fan and i'm pretty
sure you will enjoy it if you have seen
it uh let me know what you think about
it in the comments and that will do it
for this flickers of fear i will see you
guys on the next one
bye